-Our first guest tonight is an
Emmy-winning actor and director
you know from his work
on shows
such as "Ozark,"
"Arrested Development,"
as well as
his podcast "SmartLess."
He stars in "Air," which will
be in theaters April 5th.
Let's take a look.
-51% of a shoe
has to be white.
NBA is extremely strict
about it. They'll fine him.
-They'll fine him?
-$5,000 a game.
We're [bleep].
-What about more red?
A lot more red.
And what about if we
just pay the fines?
Make a commercial out of it?
You know,
it'll give us headlines.
They're going to fine Michael
Jordan for being too colorful.
-Please welcome to the show
Jason Bateman, everybody.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Welcome to the show, my friend.
-Seth.
-It's very nice
to have you here.
-It's been a little too long.
-It's been a little bit
too long since I last saw you.
You know, I think maybe
the last time I saw you --
I've seen you since --
but the last time I saw you
in this physical building was
when you hosted "SNL" in 2005.
-Yes.
-You've come back since,
but after I left.
-Yes.
It was not as much fun
without me.
-I said "I'm not coming back
till he goes."
-Okay.
-You know?
They accommodated.
-So it was the opposite
of what I thought it was?
I thought it was hard
for you to come back.
It was super easy.
-The truth is hurtful.
Now, what's going on here at
12:30?
There was
an F-bomb in the clip.
-Yeah.
-I heard you drop an S-bomb
in the "Closer Look."
-Yeah.
-Do those go unbleeped?
-It turns out the censor
always falls asleep
right before it starts.
[ Laughter ]
-So you guys can just run amok?
-We run [bleep].
I'll just say it.
There you go.
[ Laughter ]
I don't care.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-They love it.
-What are they gonna do?
-They love it. Look.
It does get beeped. Bleeped.
I've been told it's bleep.
-I've got my 11-year-old
daughter here, so let's mind it.
-Yeah. I'm sorry.
-No, she --
-But she must understand it,
right?
-She can drop a pretty hot
F-bomb.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, she has
an older sister, right?
So if you've got
a 16-year-old sister
and you're 11,
you've heard the F-bombs.
-Yeah.
And there was like, what --
So your kids are...
-Seven, five and one.
-Are you cursing around them?
-No, but they're learning it.
-You have never cursed
around them?
-I mean, I think I've cursed
around them,
but they live near a park
in New York City.
It's not like...
[ Laughter ]
-What, are they moving
dime bags out there?
[ Laughter ]
How are they hearing...
-They have internships
with some of the,
like, lower-end dealers.
-I got it.
So they're just packaging.
-'Cause I told them, "Don't go
out there
and just think you can, like,
take over a corner."
-Sure.
-Like, you know.
-They're probably packaging
and they're giving to the guy.
-It helps them learn
just more responsibility.
Because I'll tell you this.
You can lie to me,
but you cannot lie
to the guys who run that corner.
[ Laughter ]
-Now, when you do
your disciplining,
do you ever slip
and curse and say --
Is there even a "God damn it"?
-No, I don't think there's
a God d--
I'm very good. The worst thing.
Did this happen to you?
The worst thing is
when I get mad at my kids,
they laugh at me.
There's something.
I think I get mad
like a cartoon.
-Yeah.
-Oh, do you got her over here?
-Oh, yeah. She's watching
the way it's made.
-Oh, God.
So she actually came into
the studio to hear my F-bombs.
I'm so sorry.
-Exactly.
-I made it very clear.
When you bring children
under 13,
I like them to wear
noise-canceling headphones...
[ Laughter ]
...for the entirety
of the interview.
-That would be smart.
-This is a film
about Nike and Michael Jordan.
Very beautiful '80s flourishes
throughout this whole film.
-To the extent there
is beauty in the '80s, yes.
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
This was a decade you enjoyed.
-I did well in the '80s.
But it is tacky.
-Yeah.
-The '80s is tacky.
There was a kitsch factor
to the '80s, right?
The "Miami Vice" turquoise
and the Day-Glo.
-Do you think we knew it was
kitsch at the time, though?
-Well, clearly,
I think it's not kitsch
because this is still here.
[ Laughter ]
-You've muted your colors,
but otherwise this
is "Miami Vice."
-Yeah, it's like I'm waiting
for the reshoots,
but I don't think
I get the concept of the film
that's already in the theaters.
So I can cut it now.
-They might want to go back.
They might want to go
back and pick anything up.
How were your '90s?
-The '90s were quiet.
-Okay.
-Except for my nightlife.
-Oh, interesting.
-Yeah, that doesn't usually
dovetail
with a rise in the career
at the same time.
-Yeah. No, the career usually
plummets if you're out at night.
-Yeah.
-And the golf handicap goes up.
-Well, there you go.
-You know?
-The 2000s, you hit the 2000s
hard.
-2000s did alright.
-You were back.
-Because I got
"Arrested Development"
and that sort of hit
the reset for me.
-Well, there you go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
A nice way. A very nice --
-I got very lucky.
-A nice reset, that show.
-I mean, I would have done
a show half as good, you know?
Like, I was just looking
for a job.
-I got to be honest.
And I mean this.
There weren't even
a lot of shows
half as good
as "Arrested Development."
That's how good
"Arrested Development" was.
-Mitch Hurwitz
is a real genius, that fella.
Then there's that
Will Arnett on there.
But we still succeeded
despite him.
-It was lovely.
-Yeah, bless his heart.
-It's lovely,
though that you guys,
you and Will obviously
are still working together.
Sean Hayes as well.
-Yeah, we got this podcast
going.
-An incredible podcast.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Incredible triumph.
And one of the most
lovely things
is you're very supportive
of each other,
and Sean is going to be
on Broadway.
He's got a show
that's coming here.
-Yes, It's called
"Good Night, Oscar."
-I saw it in Chicago.
-Yeah.
-It's incredible.
-It's about a guy
that wins an Oscar
and sleeps with the Oscar
like a stuffed animal?
-I think you...
[ Laughter ]
No, that was the screenplay
I sent you.
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
Sorry.
-That you did not
give me feedback on yet.
-I'd check your e-mails.
-Okay.
-Are you going to go check out?
-There's going to
be a pilgrimage out here
for opening night,
which is April 24th, 25th,
something like that, guys.
-Okay, gotcha.
-Check it out, please.
-It's very exciting.
It's a wonderful show.
And he's incredible in it.
-You did see it?
-I did see it. I saw it
in Chicago in previews. Yeah.
-Yeah.
Apparently it was good enough
to make it out here.
-Yeah.
-I mean, they were in Chicago
and everybody was like,
"This is good. We should
bring this to New York."
-So I don't have to worry
about coming up
with something
falsely complimentary backstage?
-Interesting.
That's your concern?
-Well, here's the thing.
From what I understand,
on Broadway,
if you are semi-recognizable
or basically have a SAG card...
-If you maybe had a moment
in the '80s.
-Right.
And you're in the audience
and you watch the show,
if you don't go backstage
and say hi or something,
that is tantamount
to giving it a pan, like that
you hated it because apparently
the people in the show,
they know if you're semi-famous,
if you're in the audience,
and you're supposed to go back.
I think that
that's really presumptuous.
Like, I don't know the people
that are in the show.
It's like, "Oh, I'm famous,
you're famous. We should talk."
That's cringey, right?
That's very cringey.
But apparently, no, that's what
you're supposed to do.
And Sean's case,
I will do it anyway.
-And are you concerned that if
you don't like the show,
that Sean will be able
to clock your insincerity?
-Yeah, I've got skills, but I'm
not that good of an actor.
[ Laughter ]
-Do you want to, like, practice
on me?
-Want to workshop something?
-Yeah. Like, so I'll be Sean.
-Right.
-And it's after the show
and I want --
So your backstory here
is you really didn't like it.
-Did not like the show?
-Yeah, and you thought
the biggest problem
was Sean's performance.
-Right, right. Here we go.
-Alright, I'll open
the dressing room.
Okay?
-Okay.
Sean!
Oh, my God.
[ Laughter ]
Ah. You've already changed.
Right?
-No.
-We talk about everything
but the show.
-That's really good, though.
[ Cheers and applause ]
"You've already changed."
-You've already changed.
-"You've already changed."
-Oh, you must be exhausted.
[ Laughter ]
-I think the real giveaway is
that you bought yourself time
by saying his name.
-Right.
-Which he clearly knows
you know.
-And I elongated it.
-Yes.
-Seeean!
-As you're trying
to think up something to say.
-To go back to the movie
for a second,
this is, you know,
Michael Jordan.
This is the Bulls.
You're an L.A. guy.
Were you a Laker fan
during the Jordan years?
-There was a...
I was pretty cheesy in the '90s.
More cheesy than I am now,
let's say.
And I went ahead and I bought
two seats at the Forum,
which is a cheesy thing to do.
I mean, not cheesy.
It's just like
it's "I'm big time."
-It's a little show-off.
-Yeah, I wouldn't do that today.
I do like going
to sporting events,
but these seats
had like your plaque,
like your name underneath it.
They were called Senate seats.
So you own those seats
for everything at the Forum.
This is the place where
they played before the Crypto.
And so I was there for every
Laker game, every Kings game,
every boxing match,
every concert.
I mean, it was -- I had a little
credit card for the Forum Club,
the bar inside,
so that I could really cut down
on the time it takes
to get inebriated.
You know? It was a fun decade,
but not very prosperous.
-And when it was over, did
they give you the chair?
Did they give you
your two seats?
-No, they just sold it
to the next cheesy guy.
[ Laughter ]
-They were prying off the plaque
with a screwdriver.
-You run out
of money after living
like that for a while.
They take the chair back.
-When they say, "Mr. Bateman,
your Forum card has been
denied."
-Yeah, exactly.
"We'll take that back, please."
But yeah, I got to see a lot.
I got to see Jordan play
there quite a bit.
-Were you one of those L.A.
actors at the time
who was playing
in the pickup basketball games?
-There was a little bit
of a group of those.
Yeah. I was working at
Warner Bros.
George Clooney had a game there
right behind the "ER" stage.
-There you go.
I've always heard about that.
That must have been a pretty
cool game to be a part of.
-Well, I was
not a part of that.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-You were there.
You were physically nearby.
-When they got thirsty,
they'd go,
"And we'll take the bottle."
And so I'd give the water.
No, I would do
little drive-bys, you know,
to see if they needed
that extra player.
-Is that in sort of
Hollywood studio lot golf cart?
-Exactly, yeah.
With no horn.
So you kind of go,
"Hey, beep, beep, guys.
Anybody...?
Want to...?"
[ Laughter ]
No, Noah Wyle and and George
were just fine playing
one-on-one.
-Yeah.
I mean, you got to really be
willing to suffer
through awkwardness
if you let a man slowly
go by in a golf cart.
[ Laughter ]
-Just doing tight circles.
Just doing figure eights out
in front of it.
-I want to close
because you were in a sketch
I think about
all the time in 2005.
I'm going to bring it back
to the beginning.
When we met at "SNL" --
We didn't meet,
but the last time we saw
each other in this building.
And it was --
Do you remember T.T. and Mario?
Do you remember that sketch?
-T.T. and Mario. I do not.
-You and Amy Poehler --
-Was I T.T. or Mario?
-You were neither.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-You guys were doing
an album ad
for a very famous soul group
called T.T. and Mario,
and it was like one of those
like sort of '70 record album
where you're like,
"Do you remember this hit song?"
And so you introduced a song,
and this is a song
that was so beautiful
and moving to me --
and this is a true story --
my wife and I put it
on our wedding playlist.
-Come on.
-Yeah.
And I think for everybody
who doesn't remember,
this is a really gorgeous song.
Can we just watch a clip?
-Let's do it.
-I know you're going to know
this one.
Who didn't groove on this bad
mama jama in 1977?
"Roller Skate Love."
♪♪
-♪ You are so beautiful ♪
-♪ And you are my knight
in shining armor ♪
-♪ Let me put it in
a little bit ♪
-♪ Just the tip ♪
[ Laughter ]
-Really beautiful.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Really beautiful.
It was our first dance.
What a joy to have you back.
It is so lovely to see you.
Thanks for making
the time for us, my friend.
-I'm so glad to be here.
Thank you, buddy.
-That's Jason Bateman,
everybody. "Air" premieres
globally tomorrow.
We'll be right back
with Congresswoman
Alexandria Ocasio-Cortez.